Speaker 1: So we've had a lot of bad news
and kind of things to be bummed out about
on today's show, but one thing that really
brought a smile to my face was Joe Biden's
White House press secretary, Jen Psaki, just
not caring anymore when it comes to Fox News
reporter Peter Doocy and pointing out to him
that the jig is up, she realizes that the
dumb questions Peter Doocy asks during press
briefings are just to try to get one of those
absurd segments on Fox News, where the title
around the bottom of the screen is some kind
of an attack either on Joe Biden or on Jen
Psaki herself.
And so she's just not going for it.
And Peter Doocy tried to ask this completely
meaningless question, saying, oh, you know,
with Trump it was the art of the deal.
But with Joe Biden, it was going to be this
other thing related to infrastructure negotiations.
And Psaki was just having none of it.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 6: You described the infrastructure
negotiations as the art of seeking common
ground.
At some point, does that become the art of
the deal?
Speaker 2: I don't know if you're the professional
here, Peter.
You're the TV star.
You know, what's the fox?
Kairouan, I'm going to be
Speaker 6: the art of seeking common ground
does take a lot of characters.
Speaker 2: Does it?
Does the art of the of the deal would be OK
with that?
Speaker 6: Yeah, with the art of the deal.
I think that's a headline.
Speaker 2: Well, there you go.
I thought of a different kind of deal, a deal
for the working people.
Got it.
Go ahead.
So glad we could work that out.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much.
The feel of Peter Deuce's questions.
Is that he's trying to play reporter and Jen
Psaki humors him almost like he's not really
competent, but she just has to pretend to
treat him as if he were a competent reporter.
And the really funny thing is I think he's
supposed to be seen as asking tough questions
like what when he does this stuff?
I think there's a contingent of the Fox News
audience that sees that and says, wow, he's
really there and he's asking tough questions,
but the questions are so silly and childish
and not actually serious in any way that Jen
Psaki and even Joe Biden seem to enjoy taking
questions from Peter.
Like if it were actually the case that this
guy was asking such tough questions and putting
them in such difficult positions, they wouldn't
be so eager to hear from him.
They almost seem entertained by it.
And it's almost a curiosity to see what flaccid
nonsense Peter Doocy is going to come up with
next.
And you get the feeling that Jen Psaki treats
Peter Doocy and in some cases that Newsmax
reporter named Emerald, who was in the room
last week or the week before, she's sort of
treating them like you treat one of your kids
when they're having a temper tantrum and she
has young kids.
You humor it.
You allow them to say the thing they want
to say and then you move on while showing
that it's not really something mommy is impressed
with.
And that's that's the vibe I get from Jen
Psaki during these moments.
Now, after this failed, Peter Doocy tries
again, apparently with a, quote, real question.
It doesn't really go much better.
It's almost sometimes when he's reading his
questions like he's struggling to understand
because the emphasis and the syntax seems
strange.
I don't really know.
Let's take a look
Speaker 6: quickly on immigration.
The governor of Tennessee says that he was
asked and he declined by the administration
request to house unaccompanied minors.
And in coming days or in recent days, there
have been some reports that at least four
planes filled with unaccompanied minors landed
in his state somewhere in the middle of the
night.
Can you explain what's going on there?
Speaker 2: Well, as we have been very clear
about children, our objective is to unite
these unaccompanied children, children under
the age of 18 with families, with sponsor
families.
So children traveling we're traveling through
have been traveling through Tennessee.
They are simply on their way to unite with
relatives and sponsors, to meet sponsors in
the state or just traveling through Tennessee
until they reach another destination to unite
with family members or legal sponsors.
As you know, geographically, it's right in
a place where, you know, there's a lot of
states around it.
So it's a place where some flights have gone
through as children are moving to other destinations.
Speaker 6: And since this was something that
the governor of the state said he didn't want,
this is not a case of federal officials trying
to sneak something past the state level officials.
Speaker 2: I think I'm confirming here that
Tennessee is a state that is right near in
the middle of the country and some kids have
to travel through there to get through their
destination.
And we've been very clear that our objective
is to treat these kids humanely, get them
to safe homes, especially homes of loved ones
and sponsored families.
Speaker 1: This is an attempt at a new fake
scandal, which is the Tennessee governor doesn't
want any of Biden's migrant children traveling
through the state of Tennessee.
But the Tennessee governor was silent about
this when it was Trump doing the same thing.
This question, of course, ignores that relevant
context.
And yet some flights have stopped in Tennessee
in moving migrant children around.
These are government flights, mostly stopping
mostly at government air bases.
And Deucy wants to gin up a controversy that
Joe Biden is ignoring the requests of the
Tennessee governor.
The reality is that a flight stopping in Tennessee
for people to change planes or to reunite
with their families who may be living in Tennessee.
It's not really the spirit of what the Tennessee
governor is even talking about.
And this is, again, mostly the federal government
using their airplanes and airport resources
available at their disposal.
But it's supposed to be another scandal.
And hilariously, they then moved on to this
was being done secretly.
Check out this headline from a recent episode
of Hannity on Fox News called Biden Administration
Secretly Flying Migrant Children into Tennessee.
Report says now again, secretly, when these
are government planes going to military bases,
airports at military bases, is it secret that
it's just not like, oh, it's United Flight
five from New York to L.A.? To call it secret
is also a stretch.
It couldn't be more deceptive.
The reality is that the Biden administration
is just like the Trump administration, continuing
to use geographically convenient airports
around the country for layovers for children
in their custody.
And the priority should be reuniting those
kids with their families, which, by the way,
the number of kids who have not yet been reunited
is down 84 percent last month under the Biden
administration.
It's not yet a victory.
Immigration has not been solved.
DACA has not been dealt with.
But this is at least some progress from what
we were seeing under the Trump administration
administration, the reuniting.
Of the children with their families might
most conveniently be done in Tennessee or
with a layover in Tennessee.
It's very simple.
Everything is a scandal now.
And of course, unfortunately, none of them
are really catching on as scandals.
But it doesn't matter because there's this
general idea from the right, if you watch
Fox News that Joe Biden is beleaguered and
riddled in scandal individually.
None of the scandals really catch on.
But you still are starting to see reflected
in polling the idea that Biden is just embroiled
in scandal among Fox News viewers and Republican
voters.
So this stuff works.
There's a reason why they keep doing this
stuff.
You and I might see it and say another fake
scandal.
This is trash.
This is meaningless.
It actually does work to convince a lot of
people